[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
the infamous Death Eater
Bellatrix Lestrange in the mirror of
Erised said Bellatrix Lestrange was one
of the most feared witches in the
Wizarding World a fair inspiring name
and bloodthirsty reputation were well
deserved and she was known to have
murdered and tortured numerous witches
and wizards including Neville
Longbottom's parents her magical
capabilities were more than impressive
and she was widely considered to be one
of the most powerful and dangerous
witches of her time Bellatrix was of
course a Death Eater and perhaps Lord
Baltimore's most loyal follower she was
a frightening pureblood witch that came
from the strange family a long line of
powerful witches and wizards with a
twisted agenda Bellatrix was a known
proponent of the Cruciatus curse and she
derived considerable pleasure from
torturing people finding the suffering
of others to be amusing the mirror of
Erised said is a magical mirror that
shows us the deepest most desperate
desires of our hearts this is reflected
in the mirrors name no pun intended as
Eris it flipped around reads as desire
the mirror itself was made some time
before the end of the 19th century as
located in the Room of Requirement in
Hogwarts in the Harry Potter books and
films it's never really revealed what
many of the characters would see in the
mirror
given that Bellatrix was so fond of the
suffering and torturing of others you
might expect that whatever she witness
in the mirror would involve the
suffering of others in some capacity but
there is actually a lot more depth to
Bellatrix's character and I am of the
impression that she would see something
very different something sentimental
whether you want to accept it as canon
or not we know from the cursed child
that Voldemort and Bellatrix eventually
conceived a child
Delphine II Delphine his conception
occurred sometime in the mid to late
1990s in secret at a Malfoy Manor
this meant the her birth coincided with
the events of the original books we just
never had an indication of it her birth
was kept a secret by her parents because
they feared that their infamous
reputations would place her in danger
especially in the event of their deaths
why Bellatrix and Voldemort would go on
to conceive a child is unknown though I
suspect that it was more of a functional
conception a way of Voldemort care
on the bloodline of his ancestor Salazar
Slytherin the confusing part about
Delfina's conception was that Bellatrix
was a married woman she was married to
her Adolphus the strange my thought is
that he never had any objection to
Bellatrix and Voldemort having a child
because it was a source of pride for him
he was first and foremost a follower of
Lord Voldemort the husband to Bellatrix
second Voldemort was born with an
incapability of feeling love this was
because he was conceived under the
influence of a love potion the
relationship between his mother and
father wasn't genuine they didn't
actually love each other which meant
that he could never understand love
himself even though Voldemort kept a
group of loyal Death Eaters close in the
end he didn't truly care for them they
were just people that he could
manipulate in order to achieve a larger
goal Voldemort is intelligent cunning
and manipulative they can make others
believe that by doing his bidding
they're becoming closer to him
in reality Voldemort is only focused on
one thing and that is power if falton
what forever to face a crossroads we're
down one path he could save a companion
and down another he could more quickly
achieve power he would always choose
power even Bellatrix he had a child with
and who was more devoted to him than
anyone else would meet the same fate as
anyone else Voldemort didn't feel
affection and wasn't drawn toward anyone
with the exception of possibly New
Guinea to whom he showed a touch of
affection but even though Voldemort
never loved Bellatrix I am of the
impression that Bellatrix loved him very
much she was a devoted servant to him
and Voldemort was fine to keep the
relationship that way but I think that
she always wished for more though she
was evil unlike Voldemort she did have
the capacity to feel loved to feel
emotion
Bellatrix didn't just fall evaldo Mort
because they shared similar goals
she also followed him because she was
enamored with him so I think that if
Bellatrix were to have looked into the
mirror Avera said during the height of
the second Wizarding war she would have
seen herself with Voldemort the pair
would have achieved their goal of
establishing proper dominance and they
could be seen ruling over the Wizarding
World together and that's it for this
video what do you guys think what do you
think
Bellatrix would see in the mirror
I've ever said let me know down in the
comments section below until next time
you're a wizard Ari
[Music]
you